[Música]
a mediados de los 90 me encontraba yo
estudiando ingeniería en robótica
industrial
recuerdo muy bien que en una de mis
clases un profesor nos preguntó
como van a justificar que las personas
sean reemplazadas por robots
en aquel entonces yo no encontré una
respuesta y hasta la fecha sigo sin
encontrarla sin embargo he dedicado
buena parte de mi vida en encontrar una
solución para que las personas con ayuda
de la tecnología no sean desplazadas por
robots o incluso a encontrar nuevas
formas de trabajo
sabían ustedes que por cada robot
implementado en la industria
estamos dejando sin empleo entre 5 o 6
personas
tan solo en méxico hay 22.5 millones de
plazas de trabajo reemplazables por
robots lo que equivale al 52% de las
plazas disponibles en el país
en las últimas décadas ha habido un
aumento del 400 por ciento del uso de
robots una cifra que se multiplicará
cuatro veces para el año 2025
que estamos haciendo estamos dejando sin
empleo a personas que dependen de este
ingreso salarial para mantener a sus
familias
se imaginan ustedes a estas personas
preguntándose
en qué momento voy a ser reemplazado por
un robot o peor aún
llegando a sus casas y diciendo las
familia
amor ya no tengo trabajo un robot toma
mi lugar
pero qué pasaría si le diéramos a estas
personas la oportunidad de tener
capacidades físicas superiores
equiparables a las de un robot
qué pasaría si le diéramos estas
capacidades a estas personas nos
haríamos super humanos con superpoderes
y esa es la idea que hoy he venido a
plantearles
si estas personas demuestran
que pueden seguir siendo eficientes en
su trabajo no tienen por qué ser
desplazadas
hay muchas personas preocupadas por este
problema una de ellas es bill gates
quien sugirió imponer impuestos al uso
de robots como una alternativa para
prohibir los por completo o para frenar
lo que es un cambio cada vez más rápido
y definitivo
otra de estas personas es y los most
quien sugiere
bueno
que se pague un salario universal básico
garantizado solo por ser ciudadano como
otra alternativa para frenar la
automatización progresiva
en mi caso yo propongo que incrementamos
las capacidades físicas humanas para que
las personas no sean desplazadas por la
automatización y sigan contribuyendo al
crecimiento económico del país y de su
propio entorno socioeconómico
en mis años de experiencia en diferentes
industrias me ha encontrado con estas
plazas de trabajo que son reemplazables
por robots y llega una conclusión una
solución universal
un esqueleto artificial estable y ligero
que amplifica la fuerza física de una
persona hasta en un 25 por ciento de su
capacidad real
con mejores condiciones de seguridad y
de ergonomía
lo que hacen estos equipos es ayudar a
las personas
a que con un mínimo esfuerzo físico
puedan mover objetos pesados para que al
realizar tareas repetitivas disminuyamos
la fatiga y hagamos que estas personas
sigan siendo eficientes y productivas
tanto como lo serían robots
suena a ciencia ficción pero créanme ya
no lo es porque ese futuro que describió
en autores como isaac asimov quarters y
clark es un futuro que ya estamos
viviendo hoy
hay millones de operadores de maquinaria
y personal de producción que están
sometidos a mucho estrés físico pero con
el uso de un equipo tecnológico que
amplifique sus capacidades físicas
disminuye el riesgo de que puedan
lesionarse
hoy que puede ser una lesión ya sea
temporal o permanente y por esta causa
perder su empleo
bueno este es un equipo que trajimos hoy
para que lo pudieran ver
no podría operar
puede ponerle más tensión por favor
después de decir subir
bueno no lo notan mucho pero en la parte
de atrás
tenemos unos sistemas que lo que hacen
es que le damos más capacidad de fuerza
o menos capacidad de fuerza a la persona
se lo quiere al puede parar
este tipo de equipos
lo que hace es amplificar la fuerza de
esta parte del cuerpo humano
gracias
dotar a los trabajadores de equipos
tecnológicos que amplifiquen la fuerza
física es una solución que ayuda a las
empresas a que sean más responsables
mi misión es que las personas no pierdan
sus trabajos mi misión es que no sufran
accidentes que su mundo sea más ligero y
no me refiero a que solamente puedan
realizar sus tareas con menor esfuerzo
hablo también
con perdón
habló también de que no están
preocupados por que tengan que ser
reemplazados por un robot
pero nuestro siguiente paso
es aún más atrevido y revolucionario
les presento el prototipo en el que
estamos trabajando
un robot tripulado
un robot con control intuitivo
estamos buscando una simbiosis natural
entre humano y máquina
que el robot sepa cuando el humano tiene
que moverse
o que el robot le diga a lo humano
cuánta fuerza necesita para mover un
objeto
buscamos que el robot se sienta como una
extensión natural del cuerpo
imaginen ustedes las posibilidades
estamos combinando control de captura de
movimiento control biométrico control
mental
queremos que se sientan lo más natural
la primera aplicación que le queremos
dar a este equipo es para ayudar en
misiones de rescate para siniestros
naturales
para la instalación de generadores
eólicos
para la instalación de construcciones
marinas que aprovechen la energía de las
olas y porque no para mandarlos a otro
planeta como martín
para realizar tareas que un humano con
un traje espacial difícilmente podría
realizar
y con esto no solo hacer el mundo más
ligero sino también el universo más
ligero muchas gracias